[Music]
oh nice hugs thank you wow it's a rental
right yeah yeah
[Music]
wait wait wait
where are we going Felix
[Music]
oh
honestly
um doesn't mean the same for me as it
was for you in Phoenix
well why don't you come home with me
come to saltburn
all right
can I see why Felix likes you so much
you're so um
real
Oliver
I have a complete and utter horror of
ugliness ever since I was very young I
don't know why I mean because you're a
terrible person
lots of people get lost in salt Moon
this place is not for you
I can honestly say that these last few
months have been the happiest of my life
anything else I should know about well
no just be yourself but I love you it's
relaxed I promise
[Music]
um